let's go back to the phones a lot of
people holding will go to our next
caller calling in via Skype any time we
go to a Skype call it can be horrific
trolling or it can be really interesting
questions from other countries we don't
know you can conceal your identity in
any case Skype caller what's your name
where you're calling from and what's on
your mind today
hey David good enough the echo is really
bad because I can stick in some
headphones it's not but I'm using a
laptop so sounds of hurt can you hear me
oh it's will i'm rory from the UK okay
great to hear from you guys but on your
mind yeah no we were just we're just
wondering because i'm a recent student
of journalism and we just sort of had a
question on what you thought the future
of sort of the media was going to be now
that that people are obviously becoming
disillusioned with the mainstream media
and sort of are trusting as much in our
looking for other sources yeah coming
across these sort of independent
platforms that you have like on youtube
and i was we were just wondering what
you thought but that meant for the
future of media well there's another
hole there's a bunch of issues that are
all sort of existential potential
existential crises for media as we know
it and i'll speak mostly about the
climate in the u.s. although there are
some aspects that are similar in the UK
as well right now your what is
influencing media right now well number
one we've obviously had the spread of
fake and propaganda teams and the need
to have a sort of more critical eye on
what are what are what is the sourcing
that has been used for a particular
story and what are straight up fake
propaganda news websites etc etc but
simultaneously we've also seen from the
current administration here in the
United States a a sort of hostility
towards media that we've not seen in the
United States for a very very long time
and that is something that is having a
significant impact when it comes to for
example the possible prosecution not of
leakers but of media entities that
publish information received from
leakers or whistleblowers and
sort of real significant existential
crises for investigative journalism and
in addition to that in the United States
we also have the crisis of net
neutrality and as more and more news and
as more and more people opt for
alternatives to corporate media which
are often accessed through the internet
or other digital means if you have any
reduction in Internet freedom the likes
of which would be rampant if we were to
scale back roll back net neutrality you
have a combination of factors here guys
that are very dangerous
to media as we know it so I wish that I
had some kind of more positive outlook
right now I think the most important
thing people can do not not to take this
as an opportunity to promote ourselves
but if you directly fund the programs
that you believe are worthy of support
you insulate them against a lot of these
existential threats not completely but
to some degree so that that's one idea I
wish I was more optimistic about it yeah
now I completely and completely agree
with everything you said I mean it if
there's a way if there's a way that we
can take the sword
what makes hyper local news work and
apply it to to technologies such as the
internet I think it would be make for a
better sort of news platform in general
yep now if I'm a will if I'm a fish you
just could test out something I believe
that I'm able to identify British accent
down to neighborhoods I believe that you
are from the Hyde Park neighborhood of
London am i right there oh you you are
very you're very mistaken which is very
good try no honestly I'm completely
kidding I'm completely kidding
I'm completely unable to do that I
genuinely could expect wrong okay
without with Roman Way from Lincoln yeah
okay Lincoln Derry from Lincoln Co from
you so we're sort of Dodd round
yeah we're you nice you know I'm from
this guy's from Devon and I'm from South
West Norfolk ah very good all right well
guys I really appreciate the call always
great to hear from our callers across
the round
in the UK and we hope to hear from you
from you again
I think it's the first group call we've
gotten where it's weird will and Rory
are both calling you might as well I
might as well why not